[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
biggest lizard monsters from live action
movies not including the low budget
entries or from Chinese movies but we
will include two beautiful entries from
each old classics let's get into it at
number 10 we have the Mongoose lizard
seen in The Last Airbender the Mongoose
lizard also known as a mongoose dragon
is a giant reptilian creature
originating from the tropical jungles of
the Fire Nation and domesticated by the
Fire Nation citizens these creatures can
be tamed and ridden and are not scared
easily they are childless trackers and
can easily Dodge attacks without
throwing off the Riders on top of them
these massive lizards are approximately
15 to 20 feet long or 4.5 to 6 meters
long from snout to tail with bright
yellow eyes
and number nine we have the feedadon
seen in King Kong 2005. the philodon is
shown to be a medium-sized Predator
depicted as being very aggressive and
territorial attacking anything that it
perceives as a threat or a potential
meal the giant broadon is a surly jungle
predator and also a scavenger well
adapted to life prowling Leaf litter
choked Forest floors feeded ones have a
similar appearance to the notosukas
although much stockier it has a length
of 20 feet or 6 meters with a broad
build and weighs up to 2 tons like a
Komodo dragon the mouth claws and tail
are its Primary Weapons
at number 8 we have the two-legged
lizard from one of the first Master
movies ever King Kong of 1933 the
original we get to see a giant lizard on
screen the two-legged lizard is a giant
lizard monster that also is sometimes
referred to as a Giant's King this
lizard monster has an elongated body
with two full Limbs and a tail but no
hind legs similar in body structure to
the 2017 skull crawlers it also has two
digits on each hand like a chameleon or
the two toad earless King native to
Australia its neck Bears a main like
collection of spikes that creates a
break in the crest and runs from its
head to its tail it is 7 meters or 23
feet long
number seven the giant monitor lizard
the giant monitor lizard from the
classic 1940 movie 1 Million BC is
depicted as a massive reptile that lives
in a prehistoric World filled with other
various giant creatures the giant
monitor lizard is shown to be one of the
most dangerous creatures in this world
with sharp claws and teeth that it uses
to attack and kill its prey including
humans in the movie The Lizard attacks
the main characters who are trying to
survive in this hostile world the design
of the giant monitor lizard in this
movie was created using stop-motion
animation
number six the Boga Boga is a fictional
creature that appears in Star Wars
episode 3 Revenge of the Sith it is a
species of reptilian lizard creature
that is native to the Planet utapar
Burger is written by Obi-Wan Kenobi who
uses her as a mode of transportation
Boga is depicted as being highly
intelligent and loyal to Obi-Wan and she
is able to climb walls and other
vertical surfaces with ease thanks to
her powerful legs and claws the bogus
appearance is similar to that of a
lizard with a very long tail her body is
covered in reddish brown scales and she
has two small horn-like protrusions on
her forehead number five the giant
frilled lizard this giant lizard
appeared in the 2012 movie Journey part
2 the Mysterious Island it is shown in
the movie as a large lizard with a
thrill around its neck that it can
inflate to frighten and intimidate its
foes the actual lizard which is
indigenous to Australia and New Guinea
serve as the model for the giant
lizard's design the movie version
however is far bigger and scarier than
the original the characters in the movie
are pursued by this creature which seems
hostile at first but then eventually
they managed to get away by fooling it
into charging down a cliff
number four skull crawlers appearing in
Kong Skull Island and scientifically
classified as titanus Cranium Rapton
skullcrawlers have two long four limbs
no hind Limbs and a long prehensile
Serpentine tail their bodies are long
and lean yet robots and muscular and
their heads and torso stand out as
having a very notably skeletal feature
according to Godzilla vs Kong the
official movie novelization the
skullcrawlers combine features of snakes
lizards and mosasaurs but their Origins
come from a lineage of non-amniot basal
reptilimovs from the Permian period
number three the hollow Earth lizards
seen in Godzilla vs gong these large
reptiles known as Hollow Earth lizards
are creatures of the hollow Earth the
Subterranean World beneath our own they
are lined with rows of spikes and
osteaderms covering their backs and
shoulders probably as a form of defense
against other larger Predators they are
greyish black in Hue or color and their
jaws are loaded with big teeth which
they use to catch prey most notably the
arachnids this indicates that the hollow
Earth lizards are predators and they're
virtually forward-facing eyes allow them
to have a binocular osteroscopic vision
comparable to many contemporary
predatory species here on Earth
at number two we have the TriStar
Godzilla surprising isn't it from the
TriStar movie Godzilla 1998 we have the
G-Man as a form of a lizard instead of a
Titan or a dinosaur in the 1998 movie
Godzilla is not a prehistoric creature
or a Titan that was awakened by nuclear
radiation as in the Japanese movies
instead it is a mutated iguana yeah a
marine lizard that was exposed to
nuclear tests in the South Pacific most
notably the tests conducted by France
the designs of the TriStar Godzilla was
also significantly different from the
original Japanese designs this creature
was designed to be more Sleek in
appearance with a long slender body
smaller arms and a longer neck yet
having a dinosaur in posture
and number one Zetas in the 2006 movie
Gamera the brave Zetas is a massive sea
reptile guide you he shares several
characteristics with gorosaurus in a way
zeras has multiple little protrusions
that resemble Finns that extend from the
top of his head all the way to the
bottom of his tail Zetas has a big head
with a retractable thrill of various
colors he also has a very powerful tail
that is very lengthy zeros's lengthy
tongue is his most potent weapon it can
launch a strike against an opponent and
it resembles a spear of up to 100 meters
in length his tongue's tip also has the
ability to release a potent biological
acid that can kill or stun opponents
anyway those are the 10 biggest lizard
monsters from movies so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam